[Music]
tea is the most popular drink in the
world and there are countless ways we
make and consume it but if you want to
drink tea in the oldest way we still
know of you'll first need to hike deep
into the remote team ount ins of
Southwest China and handpick leads and
buds from tea trees for their hundreds
of years old it's a long way to go for
authentic Chinese tea but one person is
doing it
[Music]
my name is Shannon tang I'm the owner of
tea trunk which is a tea house in New
York City we specialize in historic
Chinese tea historic he's really
representing a pinnacle of tea culture
and these teas are usually not
mass-produced and they're trying to be
as authentic to the tea as possible it's
almost like a masterpiece of music
played versus a practice or a original
piece of artwork or versus the copies
the masterpiece tea so to speak comes
from ancient tea trees that grow in the
wild
the only bud for 15 days out of the year
so Shannon must race each spring to find
the trees and harvest them in time with
the help of local farmers the best tea
trees are always on some of the hardest
chicken to places because they need to
be on very steep slopes we usually
motorcycle a little bit sometimes we cut
water sometimes we climb in this region
it's not uncommon for two trees to grow
for several hundred years these tea
trees right now is at its prime and this
is what he is meant to taste like once
we pick the key we need to spread it out
in a whole area where the water can
travel out before we can walk fry the
teeth this step is to kill the enzymes
so that he on occasion can be stopped
then we take the tea leaves out and then
we wrote the key once the Sun dry the
tea you need to pick out any
discoloration this sorting process
usually takes months to finish because
we do have to do them one by one with
every single tea months will go by
before this tea is ready to be poured
out but the journey is well worth it to
Chinon those extreme fine points in
haste that he offers us I think it
provides us a level of joy that's beyond
anything else and my job here is to
preserve this art and hopefully even
push it to a new height
[Music]
this is kombucha real kombucha that I
see you buy in those expensive bottles
fermented in Sweden it's good but it's
not kombucha somewhere along the line
the word was lost in translation in
Japanese cha means T and this is kombu
this is the story of the real kombucha
first the konbu konbu is a type of
seaweed and a staple ingredient in
Japanese cuisine and Rishi REE island of
the northernmost tip of Japan has become
known for the kombu that grows here as
any chick Osaka is a third-generation
fisherman tomorrow our condo Mooney
namagachi
twisted you are Bonnie what the day when
I saw us was a new meter kilometer by
the food shop no keyhole not would the
doctor on our machining community
history do you consume to the city
fishes foreign honorary lucky mrs. Otto
car
how are you going when you discover
computability after kombu is harvested
and dried it can be used to make
anything from soup to salad to garnish
but for our purposes we're gonna make
kombucha
Chiharu hirokawa is a shop owner selling
kombucha made from locally harvested
kombu no oh that's you oh come on sing
the morale Kamini oh you dato a cup what
is it kombucha no doctora
let me know me Leonardo God example when
you hike we must their color Danny
totally this have to ask do you know
about American kombucha can you guess
what it's like every new Hong Kong as
the konbu know whom like
new or you also saw the computer that /
- sua Amaterasu sorry nope but do you
have any words for those seeking real
kombucha soullessness America Jane
okusama Dez Dez de chillon own ego no
kombucha Nandi tada
cuando no vamos a tener un hijo de
anaconda or - Oh nan de da da da no no
koto mo toasty nutty select eres una
rata a koala yoga pants optional Amazon
Tsubasa
waiting over an hour 40 sounds
ridiculous shocking even but this isn't
your everyday tea what they're waiting
for is cheese T so this is how the farm
can see that one coming the time singing
continues are you tired of our way so I
will use you want to punch and a bit so
you don't want me to it's all good food
supply so that's good
cheese tea is exactly what it sounds
like
tea topped with cheese I know the one
were wishing it was for change for me
what is offensive
just wait until you see thousands of the
under-told Aloha janitors I mean wagons
are just super nice title internal
tables into the Hodja circles apartment
fashion how the budgets how if a print
ad and we need a tan party and the
partition Kendall wants our soul
young-shin so you'll come to my usually
older time somebody in the home and I
know the [ __ ] you thought I was it
seeing what they don't know
and today cheese tea is more than just
the novelty it's gone global from
Malaysia to Los Angeles people are
drinking it everywhere
if I go model entices
[Music]
nothing says Britain more than nope nope
keep going
ah yes there it is a nice cup of tea we
know we have China to thank for
introducing tea to the Western world but
how did it make its way to England and
become the cultural obsession is today
well that's all thanks to one Portuguese
woman the year 1662
the person Catherine of Braganza she
just won the hand of England's King
Charles the second with the help of a
very large dowry including money
treasures and spices this worthwhile
trade made her the Queen of England
Scotland and Ireland when she arrived to
her new homeland she brought with her
packets of loose leaf tea in crates
labeled transport de Vos aromatic us
it's a theory that this was later Bree
VA T - t EA T now T could all be found
in England but was only rarely used for
medicinal purposes Catherine continued
drinking tea to her heart's content and
as the new Royal everything about her
including her beverage habits was copied
by other ladies desperate to be just
like their Idol another thing Catherine
brought to the table from Portugal was
the idea of tea drinking experience she
popularized the use of porcelain tea
cups and mugs but the end of the 17th
century much of British aristocracy were
enjoying the hot beverage and soon
enough so was everyone else today while
tea can be found pretty much everywhere
it remains a special daily pastime for
Brits hmm
so carry on and drink tea people of
England
[Applause]
let's talk about football blue 42 this
football right no no no today we're
talking about this for soccer
no it's football you have the players
the managers and the tea the tea mr.
Parrish please explain welcome to you
all to Nottingham Forest FC and have a
great time while you're here and don't
forget if you can try a cup of my Tom's
team the best Nottingham Forest is one
of the oldest football clubs in the
world
they had a great run about 40 years ago
winning two European Cups and loads of
other stuff no I'm very proud of this
team happy days but whilst those days
are gone there is still one world-class
tradition that remains well my name is
Tom Parrish I'm almost 89 now not be
long before the 90th I'm a tea boy and I
love it people do this a tea boy I said
yeah work the way out here in Britain it
was a common occurrence for football
clubs to have a tea lady or a tea boy
sadly these traditions are on the
decline but what does the tea boy do Oh
crikey what does the tea boy do it makes
tea of course
so Tom isn't handing out tea at the
sideline he has his own kitchen next to
the team's dressing rooms let me show
you around his job is to make classic
cups of tea for managers players
directors photographers that's one of
our photographers yes here's a good
loved the list goes on so Tom were your
top tips for making tea you'll get the
best tea and that is Yorkshire Tea
boiling water over the tea bag get it to
the side of the cup and squeeze it as
much as you can to get the juice out of
the tea bag put your milk in that should
be I hope a good cup of tea
[Music]
it's not just a football match it's
something that you look forward to and
it's there every week that's what keeps
you going and as I said I love it love
it there as long as I can walk and that
the club will have me I won't be here
back in a cup of tea